hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master hungry too is that we don't
know okay yeah yeah I'm playing the e3 a
couple of lines possible here g 3 e3 e4
deform so one of the upsides of the
English opening you have pretty wide
range of possibilities yeah here we
might transpose to them to iqp position
if black captures not necessary black
can also cancel this gives white some
additional options though yeah black
again here a couple of choices Knight f6
can take on c3 b6 okay here I've thought
94 would be an option let's go 94
mm-hmm okay so he does not mind me to
cheat let's do it so now go for that pin
so each 6i he wants to play h6 in this
position okay doesn't look too bad yeah
Bishop to c6 status idea maybe so let's
put this on to e5 and it should be such
a bad i QP position and do you one
probably and 9 35 yeah so i don't really
like to give up that bishop but it feels
some it's almost impossible to avoid
not sure that you will take I mean I'm
not threatening bishop h2 or something
like that okay
yeah I'm still going to play it I don't
think it was a big threat or anything
but I like to keep this piece
hmm see intending to put something on c4
maybe maybe
hmm
it's not exactly defending the Kings
side I mean absolutely not can I try to
let me try to aim a little bit some
pieces on the kingside okay now he just
actually covered a little bit better
okay so covering h6 covering before I
have Bishop b5 but then there's
potentially f6 and let me do this in
Bishop 5f six then I think I can just
take like s6 Bishop f6 but that won't
work so he avoided this turned fits
really solid here it's pretty solid what
is got here
yeah maybe just this
two minutes so timewise I'm okay
[Music]
let's put some pressure they only have
seven so yeah I can go G for it doesn't
really do all that much
I don't have to see foul its kind of
kind of sad yeah I still do it it's it's
risky but it's I don't really have much
play if I don't
all rights I don't think so don't think
this is so bad for me and that looks
like a good move though I'm pretty good
move actually I don't want to trade and
this is not exactly a very happy move
might even be able to just take a to
what it's not an easy move to make yeah
that gives up potentially at five but ok
so time were dating am if I check there
then the G file opens against me that's
not so great
check
he's got to check on c1 then it's not
not so great
I don't see I don't see anything good
chair I'm not sure if maybe there isn't
anything good but yes that's the issue
[Music]
one of the issues
check now I'm just wanting a plot here
crap really crap sorry yeah I've got two
seconds Maya that was bad wait for fits
on time hmm chill I don't know tough the
same really tough to say what's what
wasn't wrong here oops oops why does
sign end of this didn't show the window
that's weird huh just a second
okay now we are back on track somehow it
doesn't show the notices hey why well
that's kind of strange I don't know so
now i am now be okay again very weird
anyway so we had this position and again
i think most of the most looked fairly
normal okay here i could take all that
seven I surely at leasts all about it
okay what I mean it cannot be so bad yet
to centralize the pieces yeah I thought
around here this position should be okay
for white I mean what can never be worse
than this let's hear that that's really
not possible but I played it badly I
mean maybe this g4 was really too much
no Bishop see seven wins almost okay I
don't quite understand it so it's a fork
yeah I'm sure not technically not not
awake in the scam Bishop d7 it's not
exactly difficult you know f6 is pretty
terrible to beginning this this diagonal
okay so and this is probably just not
good I didn't didn't see anything
forward here I mean he f6 is just a move
that wasn't possible and I did not
punish it and it helped him of course
you're making my bishop of more passive
peas yeah this is just not very nice
Jim maybe there were some opportunities
here it it's by now by now I was down
clocking I didn't really find anything
anything good this is just it looks like
it could be something with black is
perfectly correlated and I didn't didn't
have any any opportunities so there was
this one single moment where Bishop c7
was strong other than that it was a it
was so handy equal ish but which here
okay I should probably still avoid g4 I
mean I kind of knew that it's a it's a
dicey decision but as didn't see
anything active okay thanks for watching